&gt;&gt; Hi, guys. That was pretty incredible, wasn't it?
&gt;&gt; Actually, Susan, no. We missed it. That happened really quickly.
&gt;&gt; It did happen quickly. Actually, the lowest any of our contestants could hear
was only 0 decibels.
&gt;&gt; What? Susan, 0? That sounds pretty low.
&gt;&gt; It is low, but that is actually the threshold of the average human hearing. I
was really hoping to go into the negative decibels today but what can you do?
&gt;&gt; Well, thanks Susan.
&gt;&gt; Anytime.
&gt;&gt; Well, Andy, I guess we didn't see any records set for volume threshold today.
&gt;&gt; Yeah, we certainly did not, I'm actually a little bit pointed with our
performance. But, but what are you going to do?
&gt;&gt; Well, I know on the plus side, I bet our sponsors are happy. &gt;&gt; [LAUGH]
You're absolutely right, actually. let's, let's go to them, now.